eccoci qua allora il io parlerò della
vista questo regalo immenso che ci è
stato donato alla nascita e che abbiamo
il dovere di diritto di conservare nel
miglior modo possibile perché più non
riusciamo a conservare in maniera
eccellente il nostro apparato visivo con
più riusciamo a integrarsi nel mondo
perché la visione e determinante nel far
sì che ci si possa integrare e vivere la
nostra realtà dunque quello che noi
parleremo oggi come siamo riusciti a
curare o a risolvere determinate
problematiche per una patologia che
coinvolge praticamente l'apparato visivo
quindi l'occhio e che cosa è riuscito e
si è riusciti a fare grazie
all'innovazione tecnologica
il problema è un problema piuttosto
grande perché ogni anno 50 mila persone
vengono colpite si ammalano di questa
malattia che a differenza di altre
malattie
difficilmente potevano essere poteva
essere curata precedentemente perché se
paragoniamo praticamente l'occhio a una
macchina fotografica la parte che in
questo caso si andava ad ammalarsi va ad
ammalare e la parte è più importante
dell'occhio che la kia la retina la
retina rappresenta se dovessimo
paragonare la macchina fotografica
la pellicola e quando la pellicola erano
in arte difficilmente può essere
riparata molto più facile invece se la
causa della riduzione della nostra
capacità visiva è legata a una opacità
del cristallino quindi il cristallino so
precisa molto più facile cambiare
l'obiettivo del del nostro del nostro
apparato visivo anche se come era
successo già negli anni 80 questa questo
questo problema nel mettere un corpo
nuovo all'interno del cristallino aveva
creato non pochi non poche controverse
allora il che cosa succede quando noi
siamo ammalati o c'è un problema alla
retina c'è un problema alla alla marco
la il problema è che la macula serve per
vedere nel dettaglio la macula serve per
poter leggere se la macula praticamente
a nalut ala soprattutto se questo
succede in entrambi gli occhi la lettura
diventa difficoltosa allora è come se
noi guardarsi in faccia una persona e la
vedessimo sfocata e al centro della
faccia del centro della faccia del viso
appare una macchia nera quindi diventa
estremamente complicato riuscire a
correggere una situazione un particolare
come questa allora che cosa per riuscire
a capire quello che è il sistema il
progetto la pregio la progettualità di
quello che siamo andati a creare se noi
paragoni a se paragonassimo una
il nostro apparato visivo quindi
l'occhio una macchina fotografica la
parte anteriore che è composto dalla
cornea da divide dal cristallino
potrebbe essere paragonata
immediatamente al nostro obiettivo della
macchina fotografica da camera vita che
la parte centrale del dell'occhio con la
possiamo paragonare alla camera
intermedia della macchina fotografica e
la retina anche la parte più profonda
del dell'occhio la possiamo come abbiamo
detto prima a paragonare alla pellicola
fotografica e quindi se andiamo a
rivedere come formato l'occhio vediamo
che l'occhio è formato quasi con una
macchina fotografica e la macula
rappresenta quella parte profonda un po
giallina che riusciamo a vedere nello
schermo e che rappresenta quello che è
il dettaglio della visione quindi tutto
quello che è il dettaglio della visione
viene praticamente espresso viene visto
in quell'area molto piccola gioia che
sta affianco al nostro nervo ottico
certamente se è una zona molto piccola
quindi quando è lesionata potrebbe
essere un problema andarla a a curare
parlare di macula parlare di maculopatia
è un po una cosa non tanto semplice
perché è come se noi paragonassimo la
maculopatia a un incidente un incidente
può essere piccolo di un'entità piccola
ma di un'entità devastante quindi e
anche qui in questo caso la maculopatia
a guardare da una piccola lesione una
grande lezione quando una piccola
lesione più o meno magari non ci si può
rendere conto che abbiamo un problema
patologico che si sta sviluppando ma
quando questo problema evolve nel tempo
certamente il nostro apparato visivo
incomincia a ridurre la sua capacità
visiva quindi la macula rappresenta il
target di massima visione quindi il dove
si sviluppa la maggior visione quando
riguardiamo un oggetto quando noi
vogliamo
andare a leggere quindi rappresenta
anche quello che è l'entità del di
quello che ci permette di poter vedere
anche tutti i colori
quindi se la macula e ammalata
naturalmente lascia il problema nasce la
maculopatia la maculopatia che fino a
qualche anno fa non si poteva curare
perché non c'erano i mezzi poi piano
piano sono gli intervenuti i primi mezzi
ma comunque si risolvevano il problema
ma vi sono il problema che lasciando
sempre qualche altro problema legato
quindi c'erano dei pro e dei contro da
tenere sempre bene in considerazione
e per quanto riguarda la maculopatia
dobbiamo ricordare sempre che esistono
vari tipi di maculopatia quindi esiste
una maculopatia di tipo associativo una
maculopatia di tipo secolo maculopatie
di tipo degenerativo
per quanto riguarda il fortunatamente
per quanto riguarda la patologia
maculare di tipo e sull'attivo si è
riusciti con alcuni farmaci a risolvere
in maniera eccellente questo problema ma
rimaneva sempre del problema legato alla
maculopatia di tipo atrofico piuttosto
chiede generativo e che cosa succede
quando la marco la malata
allora noi vediamo sopra che abbiamo una
macula che è perfetta in un occhio
eccellente una straordinaria questo del
resto è un ragazzo molto giovane mentre
in basso
vediamo che l'area dell'occhio
contrapposto a quello sopra è un'area
interessata da un'atrofia maculare
questo purtroppo è un occhio che alla
nascita per esempio ho avuto una
un'infezione è andato incontro a una
cicatrizzazione dell'area maculare
allora noi cosa possiamo fare possiamo
cercare di risolvere questo problema
chiaramente non possiamo sostituire la
retina cosa che potremo fare per esempio
in una macchina fotografica
perché non possiamo sostituirla perché
in
non abbiamo ancora i mezzi di
collegamento per la sostituzione della
retina possiamo se la lesione piccola
fare un intervento chirurgico di
spostamento della retina ma quando la
lesione per esempio è così di vasta
entità
questo non è possibile eseguirlo allora
dobbiamo praticamente cercare di abbiamo
cercato di realizzare un sistema che ci
permettesse di ingrandire le immagini e
nell'eventualità dato che questo sistema
è un sistema formato da un due lenti
contrapposte una all'altra eventualmente
se come abbiamo visto prima la lesione
era piuttosto e grande estesa avessimo
anche la possibilità in quello stesso
momento della realizzazione del sistema
di poter deviare anche l'immagine
certamente l'innovazione tecnologica in
questo senso ci ha dato un grandissimo
contributo perché oggi a differenza di
ieri si riesce a costruire un sistema in
grande ente miniaturizzato e questo
sistema in grande ente miniaturizzato
può essere poi una volta realizzato
introdotto nell'occhio certamente
sentire parlare di questo può sembrare
molto strano ma se noi ritorniamo
indietro negli anni venti anni fa quando
si è parlato di introdurre un
cristallino artificiale all'interno
dell'occhio il mondo scientifico ha
urlato allo scandalo perché si diceva
che effettivamente non si sarebbe mai
riuscito a realizzare un cristallino e
che lo stesso potesse essere introdotto
all'interno dell'occhio ma come ci è
successo e oggi invece sentiamo che
tante persone vengono operate di casa
alata e subito dopo l'intervento sono
pronte ad uscire dall ambulatorio
chirurgico togliere quello che è il la
benda che è stato emesso a loro per il
decorso post operatorio e ritornare a
vedere immediatamente viene quindi la
cosa che nasce oggi a vent'anni 25 anni
di distanza da quel primo passaggio è lo
stesso cioè un'innovazione tecnologica
straordinaria che permette a queste
persone che hanno una lesione maculare
di tipo atrofico al nell'occhio di poter
risolvere questo o migliorare quello che
è il loro capacità visiva dobbiamo
pensare che nel momento in cui riusciamo
a migliorare la capacità visiva
riusciamo a migliorare anche quello che
la qualità di vita e la qualità di vita
naturalmente coinvolge anche tutte le
persone che spero sono o accompagnano o
sono vicine alle persone affette da
degenerazione maculare o da una capacità
involutiva della visione allora abbiamo
è stato realizzato un primo progetto il
primo progetto come dicevamo prima
prevedeva l'impianto all'interno
dell'occhio di un doppio sistema un
sistema praticamente miniaturizzato in
grande ente che andava
a deviare oppure a ingrandire l'immagine
favorendo o facilitando la capacità
visiva del del paziente adesso la grande
invece innovazione tecnologica cosa ha
portato da quel sistema si è realizzato
il sistema ingrandite miniaturizzato ma
che va completamente introdotto
all'interno del sacco capsulare quindi
va introdotto totalmente al posto del
vecchio cristallino il vecchio
cristallino viene rimosso viene lasciato
solamente l'involucro che avvolge la
sostanza propria del cristallino e una
volta che viene rimossa viene
praticamente introdotto all'interno del
sacco capsulare il nuovo sistema in
grande ente miniaturizzato il sistema in
grande temi non autorizzato come lo
possiamo vedere può essere a linea
diretta oppure al con la possibilità di
deviare l'immagine certamente tutto
questo prima di essere realizzato prima
di portare il paziente in sala
operatoria c'è un percorso che permette
di capire quanto può essere aiutato il
paziente cosa pure quanto è il grado di
miglioramento che può tenere il paziente
con il sistema e se il sistema che è un
pochino leggermente più grande di un
cristallino naturale può essere
introdotto all'interno dell'occhio e se
possono esserci o meno delle complicanze
e viene fatta prima ancora della
dell'eventuale intervento chirurgico una
simulazione che permette di quantificare
il grado di miglioramento della capacità
visiva del paziente ora possiamo vedere
come una volta fatto l'intervento
il doppio sistema di cristallini
incrociato il viene introdotto
nell'occhio eco vediamo questa è la foto
che ci permette di vedere come questo
sistema che apparentemente sembrava
impossibile dare
impossibile da ottenere grazie
all'innovazione tecnologica e poi è
stato possibile introdurlo all'interno
dell'occhio è un'innovazione giustamente
come diceva prima gerolamo il totalmente
italiana in italia vengono quasi ogni
mese chirurghi provenienti da tutto il
mondo per vedere questo sistema è questa
l'innovazione tecnologica è un sistema
di per il momento di un grande successo
perché anche all'ultimo congresso della
crs che se ho ottenuto a milano 22
chirurghi provenienti da tutto il mondo
erano ospiti nel nostro ospedale per
vedere l'impianto e per collaborare a
quello che è uno sviluppo internazionale
del sistema a livello mondiale
il risultato che noi vogliamo ottenere
qual è quello di riuscire a migliorare
la qualità della vita del paziente di
questi pazienti che essendo affetti da
una degenerazione maculare di tipo
atrofico non potrebbero trovare con il
farmaco una soluzione innovativa di
quello che è il loro problema di quello
che è il loro deficit visivo ma con una
applicazione all'interno dell'occhio di
un sistema ingrandite miniaturizzato che
gli permette loro di avere un
ingrandimento dell'immagine e hanno la
possibilità in questo caso di migliorare
quello che è la loro capacità visiva
il sistema è un sistema che una volta
introdotto all'interno dell'occhio
risulta invisibile perché il sia
l'anello esterno sia la lente negativa e
sia la lente positiva che in questo caso
funge da da obiettivo vengono introdotti
totalmente nel sacco capsulare che
rappresenta praticamente il
lo spazio il contenuto del cristallino
naturale e di conseguenza subito dopo
l'intervento
una volta che è stato introdotto il
sistema miniaturizzato in grande ente
nel sacco capsulare il paziente ha
innanzitutto la possibilità di vedere
quasi subito un miglior percepire subito
un miglioramento visivo e soprattutto
non ha il disagio di far vedere un
sistema anti estetico come potrebbe
essere per esempio se lo stesso sistema
noi lo dovessimo applicare davanti
all'occhio quindi sun su un occhiale
perché lo stesso sistema che è
miniaturizzato all'interno dell'occhio
davanti all'occhio quindi in una
porzione esterna risulterebbe
estremamente ai grandi estremamente
invasivo ma la grande differenza che ci
sarebbe è sostanzialmente nella capacità
del campo visivo perché se io lo stesso
sistema lo vado a mettere all'esterno
dell'occhio riducono notevolmente quello
che è il campo visivo cosa che invece se
lo metto all'interno dell'occhio il
campo visivo
addirittura viene praticamente
amplificato è un'innovazione tecnologica
secondo me è straordinaria che darà
senz'altro dei grandi sviluppi di
interesse internazionale
fortunatamente estremamente importante
stiamo lavorando su questo progetto
ormai con molti colleghi anche anche
stranieri che con noi stanno
condividendo questa enorme esperienza e
questa grandissima innovazione
tecnologica grazie mille a tutti